it's kind of fall so today we're going
to be reviewing the pumpkin spice latte
America's long tradition of combining
sugar and artificial flavors oh yeah
super orange now the aroma you really do
get really do get nutmeg and I love
nutmeg might be a prison drug but I
don't look down on it I think you could
actually use this as a pumpkin spice
creamer in other coffee as well you know
if you let these guys sit for a while
grease kind of coagulates on top it's
kind of like a pumpkin spice latte lamp
that's I don't know if that's an
advertised feature that's pretty good I
can see how you can get kind of hooked
on these as far as coffee goes that
flavor is pretty much gone we're just
getting a lot of a lot of good sugar and
milk not that there's anything wrong
with that
mmm this guy gets a good three stars and
it kind of leaves my tongue desperate
for for air or at least not sugar
I could be bitter about this lack of
coffee but that would be a silly
expectation this is really jumped the
shark here because it's a pumpkin spice
latte but it's iced if it was actually
cold do I really want like a giant ice
drink to cool off you know it doesn't
quite make it doesn't quite make sense
you know these spice flavors are funny
it's like I'm just almost there but
they're kind of missing something a real
spice my kind of getting your nose a
little Mike and give you like a little
tickling sensation I think this one kind
of cheats because it really improves as
it waters down you really can taste the
coffee better in the ice one which i
think is strangely ironic so as long as
you're comfortable being you know a
postmodern individual I think this
the winner from giving it four stars but
you know the Lotte as we drink it the
sort of build your own monstrosity that
coffees become it's totally like an
American invention and in that sense
there's really nothing wrong with it
there's nothing that says that coffee
needs to be this kind of European thing
where it's always served in small
glasses and things like that
you know I mean if people want you know
in America you can definitely do
whatever you want and that includes what
coffee beverage you choose